[Music]
britney spears turns 40 years old on
december 2nd and now a source tells e.t
that this is the first year in a very
long time that the piece of me singer
feels like she actually has a reason to
celebrate her birthday i'm really
excited about it it's going to be
different you know but i'm excited the
source explains quote she feels like her
40th birthday is a huge milestone not
only in the fact that she is getting
older and wiser but also because she is
finally living and enjoying life along
with all the new experiences it has to
offer the source adds that brit finally
feels like this will be a positive new
year and not quote just another one
filled with misery where she feels
trapped and stuck i've been in the
conservatorship for 13 years
it's a really long time to be in a
situation you don't want to be in
so i'm just grateful honestly for each
day of course last month a los angeles
judge ruled to terminate the
conservatorship that has controlled the
pop star's career and finances for 13
years what's next for brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade
is up to one person
brittany
as for britt's fiance sam eskari well
our source says he's pulling out all the
stops for the birthday girl's big day
i love the most about my relationship is
the fact that it's it's so normal she
inspires me in my work and also i can
give so much to her you know we can get
inspired by each other here and there
and really grow with each other
sam is making a huge splash for
britney's birthday and wants to lavish
her with gifts and presents and
completely spoil her he's planning on
going all out and over the top to make
britney feel important appreciated and
loved oh my god thank you so much
everybody cover your ears happy birthday
this is not from me but
baby this is i'm gonna take credit for
this so far that includes a gorgeous
cake topped with roses which sam shared
on his insta story along with some pda a
private jet out of town and some
fireworks it's fun for me and if all
that isn't sweet enough sam shared this
sweet post to instagram referring to
brit as his quote wife and adding i call
you lioness because i admire your
relentless strength i'm inspired by your
beautiful heart i celebrate your smile
that lights up my world every day is
your birthday my queen pretty cute right
oh yeah well it's probably because
according to et source the couple has a
quote really deep bond adding that this
is a very special time for them as a
couple quote their relationship feels
free just like britney is now is she the
one do you see marriage in the future i
mean absolutely this is something that
every couple should do that's the whole
point of a relationship we're a family
as for the grammy winner the source says
she's looking forward to this new
chapter and to what 40 will bring a
sentiment the birthday girl shared on
instagram thursday quote me and my
fiance are so excited to be going away
god thank you for being able to go out
of the country i am blessed
[Music]